winth ptro just revealed where she
stores her Oscar and I love it what a
beautiful Academy Award my door stop it
works perfectly I love it and it's a
sort of a teeh hehe haha look we're
filming this little take on gwith pelt's
home and oh my goodness outside she's
she's got her Oscar as a door stop this
is a healthy
attitude when it comes to something like
Fame especially Hollywood which is so
rotten where nothing really is As It
Seems
where so much of of Hollywood is a
facade and just beneath the glitz and
the glamour you have Decay and you have
you know uh the decline you have the
collapse of families and you have people
selling their bodies to get parts and
you it's just pretend I mean the whole
place is just pretend and so when when
you're faced with something that is
pretend what ephemeral really fleeting
then that's a good way to treat those
glories